If my AFP is still elevated, this is a tumor marker.
After we remove the tumors, what is elevated it?
So, your tumor markers, remember.
So, first of all, all the tumor marker tests,
all the tumor marker tests are just physiological tests.
They're not only produced by tumors.
Otherwise, if you don't have any cancer,
they'd all be zero. They're never zero. There's a normal range.
So, it's never going to go down to zero.
And you don't want to.
Other things in your body make that chemical.
It's just found that growing tumors tend to make that specific chemical
in greater concentration.
Therefore, you could use it as a marker of cancerous growth.
If you have solely a breast tumor, let's say,
and you remove your breast, and there's no metastasis anywhere else
by any visual needs that we can tell with the PET skin.
And you still show elevated tumor markers after you have the breast removed.
Why are you still showing elevated tumor markers?
Well, the answer is, I don't know for sure.
Could it be that you have hidden metastasis?
That is a possibility.
Remember, even on a PET scan, remember we said,
no test is perfect. And even with a PET scan,
you have to have cancerous mass of over three million cells large
to even show up positive on a PET scan.
So, there is a possibility that there is still some metastasis in the body.
There's a possibility that maybe other cells are producing that tumor marker
and a greater concentration than our cancerous.
So, we just don't know, maybe it's going to take some time for that to go down.
Somebody asked me a question similar to this a while back several months ago
that they're, because they're tumor marker, how long does it take for tumor markers to go down?
And I said, well, I have just seen in practice that sometimes it takes a while,
even after you're out of chemo or after you're doing the right thing,
the tumor marker still stays elevated.
And the question was to think the following week, well, why would that be?
And this is very confusing.
This is why none of these tests are perfect.
So, this is why, honestly, this is why a lot of oncologists have stopped using tumor markers
because if you're going to do what they tell you to do, which is do the chemotherapy,
lots of times that makes the tumor marker go up.
So, if you kill the tumors effectively with, what's called something that will cause cell lysis,
then it can actually spill more of the tumor marker out.
And you could elevate it and the patient goes free, because they, they, they, they, hey,
I agreed to do this chemo and I'm getting worse according to the tumor marker test.
So, they've cut a lot of oncologists just don't do those. That's why I have to ask for them.
So, there isn't the perfect science to any of this.
And we get frustrated with science, but the truth is it's nothing is perfect.
And we don't have a perfect way to see inside your body knows exactly what's going on.
So, hopefully it's going to go down. That's what we wanted to go down.
We want to give this is why we don't ever just look at one test.
So, we want to look at other things in comparison to see what else is going on if, you know,
that we can look at any other objective things and some type of things.